In order to figure out how things
are moving in the image, okay.
This is, this is how they
are moving in the world.
In order to figure out how
they are moving in the image,
we have to go from world
coordinates to image coordinates.
Okay.
Here's our simple equation for,
in a font that is to small to read, but
it will get bigger in a minute.
It's okay.
We're just going to use straight
perspective projection.
We're going to assume
the origin is in the middle,
we're going to assume nothing is skewed,
etc.
So the only thing is is that we
need to know the focal length.
So little x is the focal length times
big X over big Z, same thing with y.
Right?
That's our
usual perspective transformation.
Okay.
That's X and Y, but
what about how X and Y are changing,
given how how the points are moving?
Given the V in the world?
Well, it turns out that's pretty easy.
We're going to call little u and
little v here.
The velocity in x and the velocity in y.
So these are just the derivatives in
time, so this is how things are changed.
So u is the velocity in x,
dx, dt, y is v is dy, dt.
All right?
Well, so to take the derivative
of x with respect to something.
In this case, time.
Right?
How it's moving.
Well, you remember, the,
the formula for the derivative of a,
of a quotient, right?
Meg is saying, thank God.
No, I don't have to know these things.
Well, it's just the derivative of
the top times the bottom minus
the derivative of the bottom times the
top all divided by the bottom squared.
Right?
Right.
Okay.
That's what this is, right here, okay?
Vx, that's the, that's the change,
that's the velocity in x times Z minus
the top, X times the velocity in Z
divided by Z squared multiplied by f,
that's just the constant.
Same thing down below, okay?
Then we start to expand this stuff and
we get this nice little formula here,
okay?
So when you look at it, that's still
kind of ugly, because you don't actually
know what Vx, Vz and Vy, you,
you know that they're from back here.
Well, it turns out, you can write
them pretty beautifully for
some twisted definition of beauty
in this very simple formula here.
1 over Z at some point x,
y times A times T plus B x,
y of omega and
let me show you exactly what that is.
Okay?
So here, I've rewritten it.
So this is the motion, so u is how much
it's moving at some point x, y, so
we know the point x, y in the image.
The question is how much
motion are we seeing?
So we've got the u and the v, that's
the motion in x and the motion in y.
All right?
And what it does is this formula
relates the translation and
rotational component of the point
out there in the world.
These are world T and world omega.
Two, how it's moving in the image?
Okay?
Thing to realize is that this quantity
A is just a function of things we know.
We know, we're assuming we know the
focal length of the lens and if we're at
some point x, y, we know what that
point, this is little x, little y.
This is the location in the image.
Cap X, cap Y, cap Z, out in the world.
Little x, little y in the image.
All right?
So you'll notice that
A is just this function.
B is a little more complicated, but it
is still just a set of things we know.
Okay?
So, if you tell me some point and
you tell me the focal point,
I can tell you this A matrix and
this B matrix.
I might not know T and omega, I might
want to solve for T and omega, okay?
But A and B I know everything of.